have some breaking news about the MP
Julian Knights Essex police say they
have opened an investigation into Mr
Knight that's after Scotland Yard
referred an allegation of serious sexual
assault now the Met police the
Metropolitan Police had previously
closed its investigation into the MP
from solar Hall he was stripped to the
conservative whip it's not clear now why
the case has been referred onwards we've
had a statement from Essex police and
they have said we have agreed to take on
an investigation which has been referred
to us from the Metropolitan Police
Service we are investigating an
allegation of serious sexual assaults so
that is the latest Essex police have
opened an investigation into MP Julian
night lots more coming up here on Sky
News